And thank you very much for inviting me over to the White House.
My name is Abe but in the United States, some people mistakenly pronounce my name as "Abe".
But that is not bad...
...because even in Japan, everybody knows the name of that great president,...
...that a farmer carpenter's son can become a President.
And that fact, 150 years ago, surprised the Japanese who were still under the Shogunate rule...
The Japanese opened their eyes to democracy.
United States is the champion of democracy.
Donald, President, you are an excellent businessman...
...but you have never been in the congress or been the governor.
You have not experienced being in the public office...
...but you have fought the uphill struggle and fight for more than a year...
...in the election campaign to become a new president...
...and this is the dynamism of democracy.
I would like to celebrate and congratulate Donald being sworn in as the President.